hello my name is Caleb Denby and welcome
back to review today we're gonna be
looking at a game between Michael crass
and cow against Hikaru Nakamura this is
a pretty famous game from Nakamura let's
see what happened here Knight f3 knight
c6 c4 e6 g3 d5 from Hakata nakamura
Bishop g2 Bishop e7 castles castles b3
from white and we have a pretty standard
way of playing against the English as we
all know one of the most solid shapes in
both building construction and chess is
the the glorious triangle and Picaro is
doing something similar here expect to
see c6 later in this game and akaru just
builds one big strong point on d5 and he
says you're not getting past this pawn
for the immediate future before he
builds his triangle though he takes
advantage of an inherent weakness in
this structure of these three pawns on
the Queen side whenever you see these
three pawns lined up like this there's a
surefire way to attack them and that is
of course with this move a5 and with a 5
what nakamura is doing is he's always
threatening to push this pawn to a4 and
attack this b3 pond threatening to open
up the a file and create weaknesses on
this side of the board
now he's not going to do that
immediately and you might not do it at
all in the game but this pawn in the a5
also controls this important square in
front of the pawn on b4 as well as
making this threat of coming to a for
putting pressure on b3 and threatening
to make weaknesses white plays Knight c3
perhaps because of this a4 idea keeping
an eye on it and now Nakamura finishes
his big triangle has a nice super solid
super safe structure in the center he's
gonna have the stronghold on d5 for a
while white continued now with d4
finally making this claim in the center
black plays Knight bt7
getting develops Queen c2 from white
controls the very important be for
square and now nakamura simply plays b6
giving this bishop some options on this
diagonal white does now break through in
the center with this move
for immediately trying to both break
down the d5 pawn and threatening maybe
to push this pawn to e5 taking even more
central space black continues with
Bishop a6 keeping an eye on these light
squares that White has actually left
behind by pushing this pawn to e4 here a
few moves have actually been tried
perhaps 'if I've is actually a better
way of approaching this position just
keeping this part of the center a little
bit more closed instead white went for
Knight d2 defending this e4 pawn
immediately and what Nakamura does now
is pretty interesting he's claiming that
white has overextended in the center he
is committed too much with these moves
c4 d4 and e4 and so what he does is
actually raised the tension in the
center and makes threats on both the
dark squares and the light squares and
it's asking white some pretty difficult
questions actually about how he wants to
deal with all this central tension in
the game white actually chose the move
he takes d5 which makes a lot of sense
you know he wants to open up this long
diagonal for the bishop but it turns out
while it takes d5 was fine he does have
other options like a 5 here that are
well worth considering
he takes d5 though not a bad move by any
stretch and now what Nakamura does
rather than meet his opponent on d5 like
this this would be a huge mistake
allowing Knight takes d5 and now this
diagonal does completely open up instead
he takes on d4 putting pressure
immediately on this Knight forcing this
knight to move and now that the knight
has left the defense of the d5 pawn
Nakamura can recapture and keep this
diagonal closed keep this work on a a
bit more safe we see Knight takes d4
from krasin Kell regaining this d4 pawn
and now rook c8 a very annoying move
from Hikaru Nakamura he puts pressure on
the C pawn and pins it to the Queen and
now white plays a move that I really
don't like white plays rook e1 and what
this move does it puts pressure on this
Bishop on e7 which can be very very
relevant but it turns out it unde
offends a critically important square
on f2 and you might be thinking well who
cares
like f2 how is black even gonna attack
that pun its defended this Queen on c2
even adds more support to it and the
answer is well you'll see shortly
perhaps a better move the safest move is
probably a for keeping an eye on this b5
square other choices are moves like
Knight f5 immediately putting more
pressure on the Bishop Bishop b2
developing your pieces never gonna be
terrible but instead rook e1 and now
this allows Nakamura to play this move
b5 totally increasing the pressure on
this pawn on c4 Mike it's developed with
Bishop b2 black went ahead with rook e8
giving this bishop some more options and
also keeping it defended and now white
plays the move Queen d1 and I think this
is kind of the moment where the game
officialy tips in blacks favor you have
to play a bit more quickly here you have
to play move like Knight f5 and after
Bishop f8 you have options of trading
off some of these major pieces and
improving your own position instead
though Queen d1 is just a little bit too
slow it unde offends this Bishop leaves
yourself vulnerable to to some tactics
here we see B takes c4 from Nakamura b
takes c4 Queen b6
like I said hits this bishop now White
has to play a move to defend it in this
case he chooses rook b1 and now after D
takes c4 white went in for some tactics
that turn out to simply not work white
plays the move knight c6 opening up this
bishop
allowing it to see both the f6 Knight
and once it moves the b6 Queen so it
looks as though these tactics are going
to cause black some real problems
what black does though you can simply
ignore the threat it takes on the c6 of
course White's idea was not to recapture
this rook
when white or black would get two pieces
for for the rook and instead he takes on
f6 the idea being one this Queens
attacked - I took your knight
what are you gonna do about it well
black could retake the bishop white
could take on b6 black could take on b6
and what you have is black is kind of
losing here he has a rook and a bishop
for the Queen and that's just not enough
so instead Hikaru Nakamura had to get a
little bit more creative I'll let you at
home pause the video see if you can find
Nakamura's move if you haven't seen this
game already okay here it is hopefully
you found it it is of course the key
move Queen takes F to check this
brilliant Queen sacrifice is how
Nakamura continued this game and it's
how he actually is winning this position
of course now we see we would like to
have a rook on f1 keeping an eye on this
f2 squared a crazy sacrifice from
Nakamura the follow-up comes after King
takes f2 you don't take this bishop back
with check allowing the King to escape
you first play Bishop c5 keeping an eye
on this retreating square for the King
not letting him come backwards
if he goes to f1 of course there is c3
check opening up the second bishop on
White's King so instead the King comes
up the board and now we do capture this
bishop now nowhere for the King to go
besides g4 and we can follow through
with this move Knight e5 check nothing
really to be done here for white if you
take this Knight it doesn't really help
you we don't recapture this would be a
huge mistake
allowing rook b8 check when our pieces
have to come back to defend instead we
of course play the move Bishop c8 check
this move this R it comes to f5 and now
after takes it's going to be a similar
story to the game in the game white did
not sack on e5 simply play it king g5
and now after riff g6 check King h5 f6
we have put this King in a box and we're
going to check made him shortly Rick
takes e5 was played of course the threat
was if white does nothing or tries to
defend we're gonna play rook h6 mate now
that we've guarded the g5 Square so he
took the night off the board black
simply recaptures King age 4 and now
Bishop c8 is the mean mean move taking
away all of this king's squares and
there's simply nothing left to be done
if you play g4 trying to come out to g3
simply Bishop f2 takes away that dark
and mate will follow and in the game
after Bishop c8 Krassin cows simply
resigned and this is of course one of
Nakamura's most famous games it's the
true classic nakamura style of game
where he does play you know that that
super GM level chess playing in the
center as such and then he comes up with
these wildly creative wildly inventive
sacrifices that he does better than
pretty much any other super GM that I've
seen these sacrifices are what made
Hikaru Nakamura so famous and what makes
it's what makes his games interesting
fun creative to watch and it was a
beautiful win by Nakamura well thank you
so much for joining me for this episode
of my name is Caleb Denby and I will see
you next time